[Musique]
alors tous en tirant je comprends pas ce
que j'ai tout le monde m'a dit à quel
point ma fille était belle et
merveilleuse
c'est fou comme le temps ce bien
nous autres adultes pas terrible en mars
j'étais sautes d'humeur au travail est
une espèce de petite conne arriviste
alors fait des tonnes
ça me rend d'arrêt tout le monde et baba
devant et parce qu'elle vient d'édition
qu'est ce qu'on en a à [ __ ] de
l'édition française a commenté mes
décisions
elle est toujours comme ça j'ai
l'impression que le monde mais devenu un
style tout le monde est dur donc de vous
couper me2me pêchu je suis généraliste
oui d'accord mais bon on se connaît
depuis un petit moment donc on peut
quand même un petit peu se parler non
vous êtes mariés l'été mais j'ai divorcé
je peux pas m'empêcher d'être agacé par
sa nouvelle vie il est venu avec elle
m'a plus offrant on part bientôt on m'a
dit toi tu m'emmenait à dijon pro chez
des parents c'était dégueulasse c'est la
première fois que je vois un match comme
ça phoenix par ci par là et moi rien
elle papillonne tellement d'habitude
comme beaucoup de copains je pense à
rien je passe mon tour
c'est pas trouvant d'être aussi
déshonneur c'est parfois il faut
préserver ses amis
[Musique]
j'agis par un puissant et après je
regrette
[Musique]
ça y est tu as fini même si tu veux
pouvoir tu peux pas m'empêcher de thome
et de te défendre
[Musique]
je peux pas comprendre que tout va bien
en plus d'afficher les moches